[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in allen
von mir gemeinsam hier mit norbert könig
für den sport an diesem donnerstagabend
im amt und hier sind sie die wichtigsten
themen die wir heute im blick haben
noch drei tage bis zur wahl endspurt für
die parteien und es gibt immer noch
viele unentschiedene
gas wird deutlich teurer die hohe
nachfrage treibt den preis und
deutschlands speicher sind ungewöhnlich
leer
kampf gegen die lava auf la palma soll
jetzt ein graben verhindern dass noch
mehr häuser nach dem vulkanausbruch
verschüttet werden
wir beginnen in der politik und mit dem
endspurt nach langem wahlkampf eine
bundestagswahl deren ausgang ebenso
offen wie spannend ist es geht den
parteien jetzt um jede stimme jede und
jeden noch unentschlossenen volker
dutschek berichtet
drei tage vor der wahl drei
kanzlerkandidaten geeint in dem wunsch
die letzten unentschlossenen zu
überzeugen scholz laschet berbalk viele
wähler erwarten ein knappes ergebnis
also ich sag mal so es ist eine kleine
wundertüte vielleicht was am ende dabei
rauskommt
ich nicke ich beide eine gesellschaft
als ich glaube dass bisher für niemanden
ganz klar ist wie das ergebnis läuft am
ende was bei rauskommt deswegen ich bin
ja gespannt ich bleibt neugierig ich
muss ihnen sagen ich habe jetzt noch gar
keine keinen favoriten wo ich sagen kann
also dass das ist ja jetzt also das ist
tatsächlich wahrscheinlich
eine bauchentscheidung
die wahlforscher sind heute noch für das
zdf-politbarometer unterwegs auch um
herauszufinden wie hoch der anteil der
unentschlossenen ist wir haben zumindest
heute abend dann eine zahl die wir zu
einer größenordnung von einem drittel
der wahlberechtigten liegen die sagen
dass das was sie uns als wahlabsicht
oder als wahlteilnahme absicht genannt
haben vielleicht noch verändert werden
kann in der pandemie wächst die zahl der
briefwähler experten gehen davon aus
dass inzwischen 40 bis 50 prozent der
wähler die stimmzettel zu hause
ausfüllen wer will dass seine stimme
zählt sollte die unterlagen schnell weg
schicken das sollte man möglichst per
post heute noch tun man kann aber auch
in den briefkasten des wahl- amtes die
post noch ein schmeißen das geht bis
sonntag 18 uhr ein letzter gemeinsame tv
auftritt der spitzenkandidaten aller
bundestagsparteien
beginnt in gut einer stunde in berlin
dort wollen sie noch mal versuchen die
wähler für sich zu gewinnen
ja gemeinsam mit tina hassel wird theo
koll nachher die schlussrunde moderieren
der name ist programm die letzte chance
heute ein millionen publikum zu
erreichen theo guten namen wie wird denn
dieses äußerst knappe rennen die sendung
heute prägen
also mal abgesehen von eigenwerbung
natürlich dürfte ist die 90 minuten
wirklich noch spannender machen denn
nach den 3 tri allen ist es jetzt die
chance alle sieben im bundestag in
fraktionsstärke vertretenen parteien zu
erleben bei den tre allen ging es ja vor
allem darum die kanzlerkandidaten
auszuloten aber noch nie gab es so viele
unterschiedliche
koalitionsmöglichkeiten und deshalb wird
diese wahl in gewisser weise teilweise
auch noch nach der wahl entschieden wenn
es darum geht wer mit wem am ende eine
koalition bilden kann und will und dafür
ist es wichtig die unterschiede und
möglichen schnittmengen aller parteien
zu kennen wir werden deshalb wichtige
themen abfragen die bisher wenig oder zu
wenig besprochen wurden und neben den
inhaltlichen antworten dürfte es auch
interessant sein zu beobachten wie er
ist mit wem in der runde wie kritisch
oder bei möglichen koalitionspartnern
wie vorsichtig also einschalten sollte
sich lohnen alles aus diesem studio ab
20 uhr 15 in zdf und ard herzlichen dank
theo ja und dann gibt es parallel zur
bundestagswahl am sonntag ja noch zwei
wichtige landtagswahlen in berlin und in
mecklenburg vorpommern matthias fornoff
hat auch dazu letzte umfrage ergebnisse
aus dem politbarometer genommen hat hier
genannt beginnen wir vielleicht in
berlin wo er der amtsinhaber der
bisherige regierende bürgermeister nicht
mehr antritt ja und wir sehen ein enges
rennen in berlin im vergleich zu letzter
woche hat es aber etwas bewegung gegeben
wenn heute schon abgeordnetenhauswahl
wäre käme die spd auf 22 prozent plus
eins cdu 17 prozent grüne 19 - 1 linke
13 + 1 af den neuen fdp 7 -1 und andere
insgesamt 13 prozent
für eine regierungsmehrheit bräuchte es
demnach drei parteien und wen wünschen
sich die wahlberechtigten als
regierenden bürgermeister oder
bürgermeisterin
37 prozent sagen franziska giffey von
der spd deutlich vor kai wegner von der
cdu den sich 19 prozent wünschen und
bettina jarasch von den grünen die 18
prozent im roten rathaus sehen wollen
und dann mattia ist die lage in
mecklenburg vorpommern wie sieht es da
sehen wir ein ziemlich klares bild wenn
heute schon landtagswahl in mecklenburg
vorpommern wäre käme die spd auf 39
prozent plus 1 im vergleich zur vorwoche
afg 16 cdu 14 beide -1 linke 11 grüne 7
plus 1 und fdp 5,5 prozent eine
fortsetzung der koalition aus spd und
cdu wäre damit ebenso möglich wie ein
bündnis aus spd und linke und auch für
eine ampel aus spd grünen und fdp würde
es reichen und wen wünscht man sich als
ministerpräsident oder präsidentin
gut zwei drittel wollen dass manuela
schwesig regierungschefin bleibt die
kandidaten von fdp und cdu sind da
chancenlos für beide länder gilt fast
jeder dritte ist in seiner wahl absicht
noch unentschlossen matthias vielen dank
für diese information und jetzt werden
sie sich vielleicht fragen was es mit
den zahlen für die bundestagswahl die
werden gerade noch exklusiv fürs zdf
erhoben und ausgewertet und das ergebnis
gibt es dann heute abend im heute
journal
deutschland hat die wahl alles dazu
natürlich auch online unter anderem
erklärvideos zur kanzlerwahl zu den
ausgleichsmandaten oder der fünf prozent
würde jederzeit in der zdf- heute
und damit unser nächstes thema heute
abend der preis für gas ist in den
vergangenen monaten deutlich gestiegen
so drastisch wie schon lange nicht mehr
und das ende scheint noch nicht erreicht
die einfuhrpreise für erdgas sind allein
in diesem jahr schon um 42 prozent nach
oben gegangen gründe sind zum einen die
boomende wirtschaft in asien aber auch
die hohe nachfrage bei uns auch weil die
gasspeicher aufgefüllt werden müssen
nils moni
im niedersächsischen rehden liegt einer
der größten gasspeicher europas momentan
ist er kaum gefüllt deutschland droht
ein gas mangel zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
haben die gasspeicher einen stand von 64
prozent das ist im vergleich zum
vorjahreszeitraum und auch zu den
historischen beständen sicherlich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ein historischer
tiefstand der lange winter im letzten
jahr führte zu einem erhöhten
gasverbrauch durchs heizen das globale
wiederanfahren der wirtschaft nach dem
ende von corona beschränkungen sorgt
jetzt für eine hohe nachfrage aber auch
das angebot wird knapper weil in europa
mittlerweile also der eu deutlich
weniger gas produziert wird als noch vor
einigen jahren vorhin genannten dann ist
das angebot knapp weil das angebot an
verflüssigtem erdgas lng was im letzten
jahres sehr hoch ist sehr sehr knapp
geworden ist in diesem jahr weil asien
in asien die nachfrage sehr hoch ist
hinzu kommen lieferschwierigkeiten aus
russland die folge steigende preise für
september und oktober haben bereits 32
regionale gasanbieter preiserhöhungen
angekündigt durchschnittlich um knapp 13
prozent beim beheizen eines
einfamilienhauses kann das zu mehrkosten
von 188 euro im jahr führen ein wechsel
des gasanbieters könnte zwar laut
verbraucherzentrale eine kurzfristige
lösung sein langfristig wird der preis
für gas aber schon aufgrund der co2
bepreisung steigen es wird also
definitiv teurer deswegen ist das gebot
energie sparen wo es geht ich kann bei
gleicher behaglich gehört tatsächlich
mich intelligenter verhalten einfach
thermostate abstellen beim lüften
findest du auf thermostat herunter
und dergleichen ein achtsamer umgang mit
der energie und langfristig eine
umstellung auf andere heizsysteme
scheinen der einzige weg mit der
preissteigerung umzugehen
die katholische kirche in deutschland
ringt um reformen dieser sogenannte
synodale weg war ein schwerpunkt bei der
herbstvollversammlung der bischöfe in
fulda beherrschend aber auch war auch
wie umgehen mit sexuellem missbrauch in
der kirche die zeiten in denen akten und
hinweise auf missbrauch vernichtet
wurden sollen endgültig vorbei sein die
bischöfe beschlossen neue einheitliche
regelungen linken klinge mit den
einzelheiten
das dritte jahr in folge protestieren
verschiedene reformbewegungen vor dem
dom in fulda sie wollen laut bleiben und
ihrem zorn ausdruck verleihen die sie
sagen damit die katholische kirche sich
endlich bewegt für mich ist ganz wichtig
dass kirche endlich aufhört menschen
auszugrenzen das ist egal ob das
homosexuelle sind ob das wieder gerade
geschieden sind und natürlich auch wir
frauen ein zeichen für veränderung
erstmals ist mit beate gilles seit dem
sommer eine frau generalsekretären der
deutschen bischofskonferenz zum thema
missbrauch beschlossen die bischöfe
während ihrer herbstvollversammlung
einheitliche standards für personalakten
so könnten missbrauchs beschuldigungen
in zukunft in allen diözesen besser
nachverfolgt werden das thema missbrauch
lässt uns nicht los es wird uns auch
lange nicht loslassen davon bin ich sehr
überzeugt und ich bin auch bereit mich
dieser herausforderung und der aufgabe
zu stellen weil wir das den betroffenen
schulden
für jens windel von der
betroffeneninitiative hildesheim geht
das alles zu langsam er hat als kind
sexuellen missbrauch erleben müssen die
entschädigung für die opfer sei oft zu
niedrig das verfahren zu langwierig also
ich denke es muss ein inneres wach
werden bei den bischöfen im kopf
entstehen was das wir hier um verbrechen
kämpfen während die bischöfe tagten
stand für viele auch die frage im raum
ob der papst den kölner kardinal woelki
nach der missbrauchskrise in seine märz
bistum im amt belässt oder nicht eine
entscheidung aus rom wird bald erwartet
ein ganz anderes thema ist bei all den
aktuellen krisen er aus dem blick
geraten menschen die hungern müssen und
davon gibt es aktuell immer mehr sagen
die vereinten nationen heute auf einem
gipfel zur ernährungslage
vergangenes jahr hatten rund 770
millionen menschen nicht genug zu essen
der klimawandel und die korona pandemie
verschärften die lage weiter aktuell
hungern wohl knapp 900 millionen
menschen eines der besonders betroffenen
länder ist kenia dort leiden mehr als
ein drittel der bevölkerung unter
nahrungsknappheit und mangelernährung
susan von lojewski berichtet
ganz brav sitzen sie auf ihren stühlen
die kinder der kleinen schule in ja und
dollar im norden kenias sie wollen
lernen aber sie hoffen auch auf eine
mahlzeit
vergeblich aber das mitbringen ihrer
gefäße auch hier sind die vorräte
inzwischen ausgegangen
selbst wenn sie jetzt in die schule
kommen gibt es nichts was man ihnen zu
mittag essen oder für andere dinge zur
verfügung stellen könnte wir haben nicht
einmal einen tropfen wasser um diese
kinder zu versorgen
draußen brennt die sonne vertrocknen
bäume und sträucher das vieh von dem sie
hier leben ist krank oder stirbt der
tägliche kampf ums wasser bestimmt das
leben der frauen in marsabit am
straßenrand fühlen sie kanister auf es
dauert stunden
internationale hilfsorganisationen
fürchten für die nächsten monate das
schlimmste
wir erwarten dass diese menschen schon
in naher zukunft noch sehr viel mehr auf
humanitäre hilfe angewiesen sein werden
auch in kenias hauptstadt verschlechtert
sich die ernährungslage wegen corona
haben viele menschen ihren job verloren
haben kein geld mehr für essen immer
mehr sind auf eine mahlzeit der
suppenküchen angewiesen die uci hat man
150 hilfesuchende am tag der show auf
800 täglich und es gab immer noch mehr
verzweifelte die um es zu retten aber
wir hatten nichts mehr
im krankenhaus der german doctors in
nairobis lama fahre wird der andrang der
hilfesuchenden immer größer menschen die
mangel oder sogar unter ernährt sind und
die nicht wissen wie sie sich die
nächste mahlzeit leisten können
auf la palma spuckt der ausgebrochene
vulkan weiter lava und asche mehr als
300 häuser wurden inzwischen zerstört
der lavastrom bewegt sich unaufhaltsam
richtung meer aber nicht mehr so schnell
wie in den vergangenen tagen noch
experten befürchten dass sich giftige
gase bilden könnten sobald die heiße
lava ins wasser fließt christel hs jetzt
mit einzuhalten
es mutet ein bisschen an wie eine mars
mission in schutzanzügen und mit
gasmasken sind soldaten des
katastrophenschutzes in der noch
rauchenden lava unterwegs und messen die
schwere belastung
die schwefel werte stellen noch kein
problem da die werte zeigen dass es
bislang keine gesundheitsgefahr für die
menschen gibt
das ist die gute nachricht die schlechte
die lava ist nicht zu stoppen auch wenn
sie langsamer geworden ist fassungslos
steht er vor dem geröll berg von seinem
haus bleibt nur dieses kleine stück
es ist eine katastrophe
und ich kann nichts tun
die gesamte ortschaft könnte bald
verschlungen sein die feuerwehr will nun
die lavaströme umleiten
wir versuchen es aber es wird
kompliziert denn die lava türmt sich so
hoch auf das unsere barrieren
möglicherweise nicht ausreichen es ist
ein ungleicher kampf gleichzeitig erlebt
die insel große solidarität seda blum
wohnt nicht in der gefahrenzone
sie will helfen wie viele andere auch
lebensmittel kleidung wir haben freunde
aus deutschland
die geld gespendet haben mit dem geld
wandel gestern ein kaufen die leute
brauchen im moment alles wir sind ein
teil der insel und
für mich ist verständlich
selbstverständlich war es auch für das
königspaar den betroffenen vor ort
persönlich mut zuzusprechen alle warten
nur auf eines dass der vulkan aufhört zu
schreien doch wann das sein wird weiß
keiner ob
handy oder kamera die meisten werden das
problem kennen unterschiedliche modelle
unterschiedliche ladekabel mit dem
kabelsalat soll in der eu schluss sein
die eu kommission hat einen
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt demnach sollen
ladebuchse an elektrogeräten künftig
einheitlich sein konkret soll das für
handys tablets kopfhörer lautsprecher
tragbare konsolen und kameras gelten die
eu-staaten und das europaparlament
müssen jetzt eine gemeinsame linie
finden das allerdings kann noch jahre
dauern
was jetzt deutlich schneller geht das
ist der sport und norbert ja wir haben
zunächst mal ein torefestival in der
handball-champions-league
77 treffer binnen 60 minuten da wären
wir jetzt keine zeit der deutsche
rekordmeister thw kiel hat dabei fünf
mehr erzielt als der norwegische
titelträger el rum und damit auch sein
zweites gruppenspiel in der königsklasse
gewonnen
die gäste aus norwegen die den dunklen
trikots haben den besseren start unter
anderem durch sieben holland kommt
älteren früh zu einem vier tore
vorsprung
es besteht handlungsbedarf dem
killerspiel ballverluste beim gegner
helfen dabei den anschluss nicht zu
verpassen nicola billig nach zwölf
minuten
19 auch mit hilfe von steffen weinhold
der am ende auf sechs treffer kommen
wird bekommt der thw die partie auf ein
ausgeglichenes niveau bei halbzeit steht
es 20 20 vor einer woche ist kiel mit
einem sieg in die champions league
gestartet mit kraft und hoch knüpften
sie in der zweiten hälfte waren an
patrick wiencek zum 32 29 der viermalige
champions league sieger kiel entscheidet
das spiel für sich dank torwart niklas
landin mit 41 36
es ist das borussen duell nummer 109 am
samstag mönchengladbach gegen dortmund
das ist auch das duell der trainer adi
hütter und marco rose für den ehemaligen
gladbacher rose wird es unabhängig vom
ergebnis wohl ein besonderer abend
auch sieben monate nach seiner
ankündigung nach dortmund zu wechseln
sieht sich marco rose immer noch tief
enttäuschten gladbacher fans gegenüber
das hat mir ganz oft dass man gegen ex
vereine spielt auch wenn man sich sehr
wohl gefühlt hat
dann geht es vor allem darum dass man
für seinen neuen verein das beste das
bestmögliche herausholen während die
dortmunder borussia allen voran erling
holland vor spielfreude nur so sprüht
findet sich das team von trainer adi
hütter nach der niederlage in augsburg
und vor dem borussen duell plötzlich in
der abstiegszone wieder jetzt hat es ein
bisschen mehr brisanz weil unser alter
trainer jetzt eben trainer in dortmund
ist in mönchengladbach hoffen sie nun
auf einen doppelerfolg auf den gegen
dortmund und den für das eigene
selbstbewusstsein
das war es christian dann genau wird
sehr gern ein erster herbststurm im
norden strahlender sonnenschein im süden
heute war das wetter sehr
unterschiedlich bei uns ob das so bleibt
sagt uns gleich katja ohne fan im heute
journal um 21.45 hat der kollege claus
kleber den blick auf diese welt für
sieben von uns allen hier danke für
heute gerne bis morgen in allen aber
erst ein angenehmer abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend heute stirbt es an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee das war das
sturmtief tim das morgen aber bereits
das baltikum erreicht haben wird es gab
windgeschwindigkeiten bis 100 kilometer
pro stunde auf dem brocken im harz aber
es war nicht nur sehr stürmisch in
deutschland sondern zum teil auch sehr
sonnig wenn sich der nebel wie hier zum
beispiel an der donau aufgelöst hatte
dann strahlte die sonne in
süddeutschland und die temperaturen
stiegen zum teil über 25 grad jetzt der
nacht ist es in süddeutschland häufig
klar im norden dagegen meist bedeckt da
fällt hier und da auch noch ein bisschen
regen und an der ostsee kann der wind
noch richtig heftig pfeifen die
temperaturen unter den dichteren wolken
sinkt auf 14 bis 10 grad unter klaren
sternenhimmel geht es auf 10 bis 6 grad
rotter und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 16 grad auf
rügen und 24 grad am oberrhein das wird
ein ruhiger tag in norddeutschland mit
vielen wolken selten mal sonne und
westwind im süden dagegen strahlt noch
mal die sonne und am samstag kann sich
die sonne dann auch in norddeutschland
wieder häufiger zeigen bei 16 bis 26
grad und der sonntag wird spannend denn
von südwesten kommen schauer und
gewitter heran die bis montag auch den
norden und nordosten erreichen guten
abend